مندوبه هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا التقارب
يتسارع بين روسيا والصين اجمعوا من جديد
الجمعه اليوم بين الرئيسين الروسي والصيني
الرئيس الروسي دعنا نظيره الصيني الى
زياره موسكومه العام المقبل للتاكيد كما
قال على مكانه التحالف الاستراتيجي بين
البلدين وودها ايضا الى تعزيز التعاون
العسكري الرئيس الصيني من جهه يشدد على ان
الصين ستحافظ على موقفها المحايد والعادل
على حد وصفه فيما يتعلق بالحرب اوكرانيا
همم اهلا بك استاذ نادر من خلال يعني ما
وصلنا من تصريحات حتى هذه اللحظه
الاجتماعيه بمره اخرى
من يدفع نحو بناء هذا التحالف همم بشكل
همم كما يصف الاستراتيجي حقا وقائم مع
الصين هو من دعا الرئيس الصيني الى زياره
موسكو اللي يبرهن للعالم كما قال على هذا
التحالف وداع ايضا الى تعزيز التعاون
العسكري على غير البنت تبع التعاون
الاقتصادي هل برايك الصين تستحقا الى
تعارف حقيقي مع روسيا اما يهمها اكثر هو
تحالف وجهها فقط
اهلا ومرحبا بكم اولا يعني تؤمنوا او
تتمسكوا في ماده وعدم عدم الانحياز يعني
والتعاونه
[موسيقى]
استراتيجيه الشامله ولكن
التحالفات العسكريه ضد اي دوله في العالم
لذلك
اولا السيد
علاقاتها مع روسيا وكذلك يعني الاستعداد
هذه
همم ثم الصين ايضا اعرفت انها همم يعني
تتمسك به مواقف حياته اتجاه الازمات
الاخرانيه وكذلك تقدر جهود همم
الاستئناف للمفاوضات وتحقيق
ذلك النهار
فهذا هو لكنها لا تريد همم استاذ نادر
يعني لكن الصين وذلك ربما ما نفهمه اليوم
من كلام الرئيس الصيني همم على عكس دعوات
حتى من فرنسا مثلا لان تكون الصين وسيط
لانها هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا الصين ليست
مستعده او على الاقل ربما ليست لها
امكانيه ولا رغبه في لعب هذا الدور هذا هو
الانطباع السائد داخل البيكينج
تتمسك بمبدا عدم التدخل في شؤون الداخليه
[موسيقى]
على نار فترى ان العقوبات والتبادل
الاتهامات لا يفيد
[موسيقى]
ستاتي كل هذه التسعيد همم
يعني همم
في النتائج السلبيه او معناه
الشعب الاخراني وكذلك الشعوب في اوروبا
فلذلك همم
اصلا استراتيجيه في هذه المنطقه تحديدا
الرئيس الروسي اليوم قال انه بدا انه
يتباهى بان روسي اصبحت اول مورد للنفط
الصين في المقابله ربما بعد المباراه
راقبين يرى ان الصين هي الرابح في الواقع
لانها تزيد من اعتماد موسكو عليها في
مقابل الانسحاب ربما
الاوروبيين والتخفيف طلبهم على النفط
الروسي هل هذا المعطى معلن صراحه داخل
الصين مساله ربما التحكم في موسكو وجعلها
معتمد على السنه بشكل اكبر
لا لن اعتقد ذلك في الحرب ودائما اكل
الصيني في اي حرف يعني لا يوجد فائده في
اي حرف
كذلك لان هناك الازمه الطاقه وكذلك اجمل
غذائيه في العالم هناك ابواب غير مستقر
يعني الناجمه عن هذه الازمه الصين
في التعاون مع روسيا فالصين تعرض فرض
العقوبات بشكل حديث وكذلك
مهما تربيته بين الصين وروسيا هو انهما اا
تعرضان الحيمه وكذلك
النظام همم
احاديث همم
دوله هاين تعمل الان على دفع
العلمي في اتجاه
بتاعته شكرا جزيلا لك الصحفي نادر رومك هو
ان كنت معنا من بكينا